GOD'S COUNTRY WHICH MEANS IT'S
TIME FOR "FOX NEWS PRIMETIME"
I'M YOUR HOST PETE HEGSETH
TONIGHT AND THE REMAINDER OF THE
WEEK OVER OTHER NETWORK IS
OBSESSING OVER YESTERDAY'S NEWS.
THE CONGRESSMAN WOMAN FROM D.C.,
LOUISIANA CHENEY HER TIME IS UP,
PIE BYE.
MAYBE THAT'S THE STORY THE
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA WANT US TO BE
COVERING.
THE SHINY OBJECT DISTRACTION IS
A VERY POWERFUL DEVICE AND WE
FALL FOR IT OFTEN.
WHAT IF I TOLD YOU INSTEAD A FAR
MORE SINISTER AND DANGEROUS
EFFORT IS UNDERWAY RIGHT UNDER
OUR NOSES RIGHT NOW AT THE
PENTAGON?
SOMETHING I KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT.
I HAVE BEEN IN THE MILITARY FOR
THE BETTER PART OF TWO DECADES.
I WAS IN THE ARMY NATIONAL GUARD
UNTIL LAST MONTH.
WE ALL SAW THIS COMING.
AND NOW IT'S HERE.
THIS
♪ JUST THE WOKE MILITARY STUFF
YOU HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT.
THIS IS NOT EXTREMISM STANDDOWN
OR A SOCIAL DISTANCING READING
LIST OR EVEN A FOOLISH CIA
RECRUITMENT VIDEO WE HAVE ALL
SEEN BY NOW.
THIS IS WORSE.
THIS IS WAY WORSE.
THIS, MY FRIENDS, IS A PURGE.
A PURGE OF THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT LED BY A NEW AND NOW
POWERFUL RADICAL LEFTISTS.
A 1619 PROJECT ACTIVIST, A HARD
CORE SOCIAL DISTANCING DEMOCRAT.
A MAN WHO BELIEVES ALL, ALL
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE RACIST AND
EXTREMISTS.
AND WHAT MUST WE DO TO RACISTS?
WE MUST DEFINE THEM AND THEN WE
MUST PURGE THEM.
SO WHO IS THE PENTAGON'S NEWLY
MEANTED MAGA PURGE MAN?
WELL, MEET BISHOP GARRISON, THE
NEW SENIOR ADVISER TO THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
HIS PORTFOLIO IS DIVERSITY,
EQUITY AND INCLUSION.
BUT HIS PURVIEW IS MUCH WIDER.
NEVER HEARD OF HIM?
ME NEITHER.
THEY LIKE IT THAT WAY.
BISHOP GARRISON HAS BEEN AT THE
JOB AT THE PENTAGON FOR FOUR
MONTHS NOW HIRED IN THE WAKE OF
THE EVENTS OF JANUARY 6TH.
THE ONGOING AND ULTIMATE
JUSTIFICATION.
THEY SENT 25,000 TROOPS TO THE
CAPITOL, BUILT A WALL AROUND IT,
AND NOW THE REST BEGINS.
ACCORDING TO AN OFFICIAL DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT MEMO SIGNED ON
APRIL 9TH, LESS THAN A MONTH
AGO, BY THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE, LLOYD AUSTIN HIMSELF,
BISHOP GARRISON IS NOW IN CHARGE
OF COUNTERING EXTREMISM WORKING
GROUP.
THE GROUP'S FIRST MEETING WAS
APRIL 14TH.
THEY MEET WEEKLY.
MAYBE THEY MET TODAY.
THERE IS WORK TO BE DONE.
THE PENTAGON'S COUNTERING
EXTREMISM WORKING GROUP, WHICH
IS A TOP DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
PRIORITY IS IMMEDIATELY CHARGED
WITH THE FOLLOWING.
GET THIS.
REVIVING THE DEFINITION OF
PROHIBITED EXTREMIST ACTIVITIES.
CREATING A REPORTING PROCESS FOR
VETS, SOLDIERS WHO HAVE LEFT THE
FORCE TO REPORT EXTREMIST
GROUPS.
SO NOW WE HAVE A VETERAN SPY
NETWORK ESSENTIALLY.
AND FORMING YET ANOTHER
COMMISSION TO STUDY EXTREMIST
BEHAVIOR IN THE MILITARY.
THERE'S MORE.
THIS WORKING GROUP WILL ALSO
RECOMMEND CHANGING THE MILITARY
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS EXTREMISM.
GOOD.
WOKE JUSTICE.
ENHANCE THE MILITARY'S INSIDER
THREATS PROGRAMS TO REPORT
CONCERNING BEHAVIORS.
THIS USED TO BE FOR, SAY,
FOREIGN SPIES?
I'VE DONE THE TRAINING BUT NOT
ANYMORE.
WE HAVE NEW INSIDER THREATS.
SCREENING PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION ON NEW RECRUITS WITH
CONTINUOUS VETTING TO INCLUDE
ALGORITHMS INTO SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS.
BETTER CHECK YOUR KID'S PHONE IF
YOU WANT HIM OR HER TO BE A
STAFF SERGEANT SOME DAY.
I HOPE THEY DIDN'T TIKTOK ABOUT
TRUMP OR CALL THE ELECTION
RIGGED.
THE RECRUITER WILL NOT TOLERATE
THAT.
AND FINALLY, THEY ARE GOING TO
UPDATE ALL TRAINING, ESPECIALLY
ON GRAY AREAS SUCH AS READING,
FOLLOWING, OR LIKING EXTREMIST
MATERIAL ONLINE.
CATCHALL THAT?
THEY ARE GOING TO REDEFINE
EXTREMISM, EMPOWER VETERANS TO
SURVEIL EACH OTHER, REEVALUATE
HOT REAL INSIDER THREATS ARE.
SCREEN THE SOCIAL MEDIA OF NEW
MILITARY RECRUITS AND UPDATE ALL
TRAINING MATERIALS.
OH, BUT THE BIG QUESTION IS WHO
IS DECIDING WHAT'S EXTREME?
WELL, BISHOP GARRISON, OF
COURSE, WITH THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE RIGHT BEHIND HIM.
NOW, BISHOP GARRISON IS A WEST
POINT GRAD, SERVED TWO OVERSEAS
TOURS AND HOLD TWO BRONZE STARS
IT FOR HIS SERVICE AND WE
SINCERELY THANK HIM FOR THAT BUT
WHAT DOES BISHOP GARRISON
BELIEVE TODAY AS A CIVILIAN?
IS HE REALLY RADICAL?
MAYBE HE IS JUST ANOTHER, YOU
KNOW, HILLARY CLINTON OR
BIDEN-HARRIS STAFFER WHICH HE
WAS.
HOW DO I PUT THIS?
THE WHITE HOUSE JUST PUT THE
EQUIVALENT OF EBRAHIM X CONTENDY
THE AUTHOR OF HOW TO BE AN ANTI
RACIST IN CHARGE OF VETTING THE
ENTIRE U.S. MILITARY.
PAST, PRESENT, AND FUTURE.
A BELIEVER THAT OUR FOUNDING WAS
IN 1619 WILL NOW BE VETTING OUR
ARMED SERVICES A FEW OF WHICH GO
BACK TO 1776.
AND SINCE WE ARE IN THE MOOD FOR
VETTING THE MILITARY, LET'S
CHECK A FEW OF BISHOP GARRISON'S
PAST TWEETS AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF THEM.
JULY OF 2019, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
PENTAGON'S BRAND NEW SENIOR
ADVISER SENT THESE TWO TWEETS
SUPPORT FOR HIM, MEANING TRUMP,
A RACIST, IS SUPPORT FOR ALL HIS
BELIEFS.
ALSO TWEETING HE IS DRAGGING A
LOT OF BAD ACTORS, MISOGYNISTS,
EXTREMISTS AND RACISTS OUT INTO
THE LIGHT NORMALIZING THEIR
ACTION.
IF YOU SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT,
YOU SUPPORT THAT.
THERE IS NO ROOM FOR NUANCES
WITH THIS.
THERE IS NO ROOM FOR NUANCES.
IF YOU SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT,
YOU SUPPORT EXTREMISTS AND
RACISTS.
YOU SUPPORT ALL OF HIS BELIEFS
AS WE DEFINE THEM.
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
BISHOP GARRISON SAID FAR WORSE
ABOUT TRUMP FOR YEARS.
BUFF THAT'S NOT THE POINT.
THE SCARY PART IS WHAT HE
BELIEVES ABOUT ANYONE WHO
SUPPORTS TRUMP.
YOU ARE RACIST.
YOU ARE AN EXTREMIST.
THE EQUATION IS SIMPLE FOR
BISHOP GARRISON.
IF YOU SUPPORT TRUMP, AND
SUPPORTING TRUMP MAKES YOU A
RACIST AND EXTREME, THEN IN THE
WORLD OF BISHOP GARRISON, TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ARE DE FACTO
EXTREMISTS.
NO NUANCES.
NO QUESTION.
NO CORRIDOR.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT WHITE SUPREMACY
OR WHITE NATIONALISM.
THOSE VIEWS AND TATTOOS HAVE
BEEN BANNED IN THE MILITARY FOR
A LONG TIME.
IF I HAD A WHITE SUPREMACIST OR
RACIST IN MY INFILL TRI PLATOON
I COULD AND WOULD KICK THEM OUT.
I WOULD HAVE THE DUTY.
BUT I DIDN'T HAVE TO BECAUSE IT
WASN'T AN ISSUE.
I SERVED WITH BLACK, BROWN, AND
WHITE SOLDIERS.
BUT IN ALL HONESTY, ALL I EVER
SAW WAS ARMY GREEN THAT'S WHAT
THE ARMY TAUGHT ME AND THAT'S
HOW I LED ME MAN.
FOR BISHOP GARRISON ALL HE SEES
IS RED.
MAGA RED.
BUT, PETE, THIS IS JUST A STUDY
TO, YOU KNOW, COMMITTEE TO STUDY
EXTREMISM.
NOT POLITICAL PERSUASION.
OH, REALLY?
THINK AGAIN.
IT ACTUALLY GETS WORSE.
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR, ELITE
17-PAGE DARPA IT IS THE PENTAGON
RESEARCH LAB MARKED CLASSIFIED
OUTLINED EXTREMISM AND INSIDER
THREATS TO THE DID.
OD.
THE DOCUMENT IS VERY STARTLING
AND WOULD BE RESOURCE MATERIAL
FOR BISHOP GARRISON.
IT'S THE TYPE OF FERTILE DOD
CULTURAL SOIL HE IS STANDING ON
RIGHT NOW.
NOT ONLY DOES THIS DOCUMENT
ASSERT THAT EXTREMISM IS RAMPANT
IN THE MILITARY, SUGGESTS A NEW
FORM OF EXTREMISM I HAD NEVER
HEARD OF IN THE MILITARY CALLED
PATRIOT EXTREMISM.
THE DOCUMENT DEFINES PATRIOT
EXTREMISM AS THIS IDEOLOGY HOLDS
THAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS
BECOME CORRUPT HAS OVERSTEPPED
ITS CONSTITUTIONAL BOUNDARIES
WHO IS NO LONGER CAPABLE OF
PROTECTING THE PEOPLE AGAINST
FOREIGN THREATS.
WAIT, SO THINKING THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IS CORRUPT HAS
OVERSTEPPED ITS CONSTITUTIONAL
BOUNDARIES AND CAN'T DEFEAT
FOREIGN THREATS MAKES YOU AN
EXTREMIST?
THOSE VIEWS ARE MAINSTREAM
CONSERVATIVE THINKING TODAY.
THOSE ARE DANGEROUS, DANGEROUS
WORDS.
OR MAYBE THAT'S THE POINT.
WE'RE ALL RADICALS.
MAY I REFER YOU, DARPA, SAY, TO
THE DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE?
THE DOCUMENT GOES ON TO NAME
ANARCHISTS AND RACISTS AS WELL
AND USES THIS PHOTO COLLAGE OF
EXTREMIST SYMBOLS.
MANY OF THESE SYMBOLS ARE RACIST
OR ANARCHIST BUT COME AND TAKE
IT?
YOU SEE THAT FLAG IN THE UPPER
LEFT CORNER THAT'S AS COMMON AS
A MILITARY PHRASE OR TATTOO OR
T-SHIRT AS YOU ARE EVER GOING TO
SEE ON PRIVATE MURPHY.
IN FACT, I HAVE TWO T-SHIRTS OF
THAT AT MY HOUSE.
NOT INCLUDING THIS ONE THAT WAS
A LIGHTER AT THE START OF
COVID-19 DON'T TAKE MY TOILET
PAPER.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT JANUARY 6TH
OR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WOKE PC AND CURRICULUM TAUGHT TO
KIDS THESE DAYS THE U.S.
MILITARY IS REALLY FULL OF
EXTREMISTS AND RACISTS.
MAYBE I JUST MISSED IT.
OF COURSE NOT.
ON APRIL 20TH OF THIS YEAR, LESS
THAN A MONTH AGO, TWO OF
AMERICA'S TOP GENERALS THE HEAD
OF U.S. STRATEGIC COMMAND AND
THE HEAD OF U.S. SPACE COMMAND
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE SENATE
ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE.
BOTH WERE ASKED IF EXTREMISM IS
A PROBLEM IN THEIR RANKS.
>> I AM VERY CONFIDENT THAT THE
NUMBER OF EXTREMISTS IN MY
FORCES IS ZERO.
IF THERE ARE ANY EXTREMISTS IN
MY ORGANIZATION, ONE, THEY HIDE
IT VERY WELL.
AND, TWO, IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
TIME UNTIL I GET TO THEM.
>> I WOULD TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
THAT WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
THAT SECRETARY AUSTIN HAS ASKED
US TO DO IN TERMS OF TRAINING
AND AWARENESS.
BUT, IN MY ORGANIZATION, I WOULD
SAY THAT NUMBER IS ZERO.
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER, I HAVE NOT
SEEN THAT.
SO, I BELIEVE IT'S CLOSE TO ZERO
IN MY ORGANIZATION IF NOT ZERO.
>> Pete: ZERO OR CLOSE TO ZERO.
AND IF WE FIND THEM, WE WILL GET
THEM.
NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
WHO IS DISPATCHED TO QUICKLY
DISPEL THOSE FOOLISH NOTIONS?
YOU GUESSED IT, BISHOP GARRISON.
>> WE WOULD BE REMISS IF WE
DIDN'T ADMIT TO THE FACT THAT
THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH
EXTREMIST BEHAVIOR WITHIN THE
MILITARY.
THAT IS TO SAY THAT ONE
EXTREMIST IS ONE TOO MANY.
>> THE PURGE IS COMING.
THEY SEE THEIR OPENING.
THEY HAVE THE POWER.
AND THEY HAVE THEIR MEN IN THE
RIGHT PLACES.
THEY SAY EXTREMISM IS A HUGE
PROBLEM.
THEIR MAN SAYS TRUMP SUPPORTERS
ARE EXTREMISTS, FULL STOP.
SO WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, PATRIOTS, AND
CONSERVATIVES IN THE MILITARY
TODAY?
VETTED, CLOSETED, OR WORSE
KICKED OUT.
THE LEFT KNOWS THAT THE MILITARY
IS ONE OF THE LAST TRADITIONAL
AGGRESSIVE VALUE-BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN AMERICA.
SO THEY MUST DISMANTLE IT AS
WELL.
IT STARTED UNDER OBAMA.
NOW IT'S ON HYPER SPEED.